[Music]
my first guest tonight has her own
late-night talk show Chelsea Lately on e
and her new movie fun size is in
theaters right now let's take a look
o hearin what do you think I think
people might misinterpret what you mean
by trick-or-treat that's what you're
taking Albert out it oh no I forgot to
tell you you're gonna watch over tonight
I'm going to a party with Kievan a party
with Kievan why are you saying his name
like that it's not even a name mom
you're either Kevin or you're Stephen
Kevin does not exist
Kevin does exist and he is kind and
employed no mom I did not agree to this
please don't do this to me honey if you
watch Albert tonight I'll sign the
application for NYU tomorrow and then
this time next year you're gonna be
trick-or-treating the West Village I
love you thank you you're welcome
I want to discuss something right away
I'm repressed as you know that sexy
schoolgirl outfit you are wearing that
works for me you know that was very hot
what you were wearing
it kind of did oh I mean you know I
don't know what turned me on right I'm
kind of dead down there but
you knew that is that sure was he's that
down there I don't look at me Oh Andy
you can tell her I can't tell if you're
like a very sexual person or not I mean
I don't know you well enough to know you
know like what you're into I have I
think I'm a sexual person yes I believe
I'm a very sexual person who's tightly
constrained and I think that's the
inherent comedy of my situation right
III but I believe underneath that suit
you probably have a pretty decent body
kind of thing very very good guess yes I
have an amazing I have a v-shaped torso
and I'm a whole lot of man you are I
mean he's nothing compared to that but I
think that you
I think that you are definitely packing
some serious Heat well thank you so much
oh god no it's not about you you're
playing a mom to a teenager in this
movie tell us about yourself as a
teenager what kind of team I was
terrible I mean this is what I want to
have a child because of the Karma and
having what I did in my parents was that
awful I mean I used to like jump off the
roof to go to parties I mean I like
rolled joints in my kitchen I mean my
parents my mom didn't even know what
marijuana was sorry to touch you down
there things are starting to happen do
it again
I guess I mean I was terrible I was the
worst kid you could ever imagine I mean
I you know I would got pregnant and I
mean I was just a disaster
I was from New Jersey so there wasn't a
lot of options well oh my god it's a lot
of information for you to handle on yeah
I'm blanking out right now okay well
tell us about real life I would have had
a 20 year old or something
right but I did but I don't right sorry
that's not really funny I was just
exercising it's not funny at all I don't
know why I started laughing I just
thought about me having a 20 year old
child that's half black half white that
would not that would have been funny cuz
I was dating 50 cent when I was in high
school also that's why I'm finding if I
say nothing we get the best everyone
just relax you gonna okay tell us about
your life now examined your your past a
lot of hot young men in this movie what
you're a single woman out there in the
world what kind of fellow do you like I
like older men generally I mean younger
guys are pretty stupid I find you know I
like men who know what they're doing
there that our culture that are traveled
the guys I had a boyfriend in this movie
that was like he was 20 years old to my
37 so that wasn't that's not gonna work
out so you don't like a young guy you're
actually looking for the guy with the
silver in his hair who's got a little
silver in your hair no I like a guy that
knows a way around you know a woman I
didn't look like a guy who knows what
he's doing I don't want some like you
know whatever the situation or whatever
from the Jersey Shore that doesn't do it
like good really good looking guys I
don't like either okay what about all
right you said that you know like that
what about any restrictions or anything
it's like completely out like if a guy
shows up and he's got a giant mustache
no it's not happening for Chelsea well
if I'm on the set of a 70s porn that
would be fine
Thank You scenario that is the scenario
I'm describing okay yeah no mustaches
are no good no no I don't want to how
about Harry Harry chess I have someone
always confuse cuz I some women say II
when they see a guy with has hair on his
chest another women say they love it
what's the story I mean I don't think it
matters I mean as long as there's not
hair like overlapping on to the other
side you know a little hair on your
chest is fine what I mean who cares it's
just hair we've all got hair you know as
long as I don't have hair on my chest I
don't have a problem we've learned a lot